was haben sie gedacht was ging ihnen
durch den kopf als sie heute morgen
diese hammer nachricht gehört haben
dafür die republikaner ist das der
supergau und die demokraten werden ganz
still und heimlich ein fläschchen
champagner öffnen
meinen sie nicht auch dass es vielleicht
am ende donald trump im wahlkampf
vielleicht nutzen könnte wir sprachen
vorhin ob das vielleicht sogar zu einer
heldin geschichte werden könnte mit der
er im prinzip seine aussagen des virus
muss man jetzt nicht ganz so ernst
nehmen dann doch noch unterlegen
unterfüttern kann
nein
in sams wahlkampf ist alleine darauf
zugeschnitten dass er die mengen an
zieht dass er der lautsprecher ist dass
er den takt burgen denn wir haben von
allen anderen republikanischen
wahlkämpfern so gut wie nichts
mitbekommen heißt pence ist ja kein
schlechter wahlkämpfer wenn man ihn mal
beobachtet aber im schatten von donald
trump kammer überhaupt nicht zu vertun
fans kann die rolle von donald trump
nicht einnehmen der amerikanische
wahlkampf also der republikanische
wahlkampf ist so oft raum zugeschnitten
dass in dem moment in dem tram wegfällt
da wirklich eine lücke entsteht das kann
zwar sein dass irgendwie dann sozusagen
noch an die die türen geklopft wird das
weiterhin die apps funktionieren dass
tweets abgesetzt
aber das ist es nicht der präsident war
omnipräsent trump war ständig da ist
ständig über social media und über die
die lokalen fernsehen nachrichten in die
haushalte gekommen
und das kann er auf die art und weise
wie er es gemacht hat jetzt nicht mehr
tun und das ist ein anschlag in die
kniekehlen für den republikanischen
barker was erwarten sie konkret für
konsequenzen wie wird sich das
stimmungsbild vielleicht sogar ganz
brutal ändern da durch die mobilisierung
ist ja das zentrale element im
amerikanischen wahlkampf es gehen ja
gewöhnlich so etwas mehr als 50 prozent
wählen
deutlich weniger als das etwa in der
bundesrepublik der fall ist jedenfalls
bei bundeswahlen und deswegen kommt es
darauf an diese 23 4% zu mobilisieren
macht ja gut sein dass amerikanerinnen
und amerikaner sich entweder für beiden
oder für trump entschieden haben aber
das heißt ja noch lange nicht dass sie
wählen gehen und dieses moment jemanden
dazu zu bringen wirklich zur wahl zu
gehen
das ist etwas das hat trump geliefert
das hat sein ganzer apparat nicht
geliefert das konnte auch hens eben
nicht liefern
und deswegen ist schon jetzt zu vermuten
dass sich möglicherweise der umfragen
gar nicht so viel ändert aber im
wahlergebnis etwas ändert weil eben
diese mobilisierung so nicht erfolgt und
dann müssen wir mal abwarten wie es im
weißen haus weitergeht als im umfeld von
mike pence
corona infektion war musste der
vizepräsident auf abstand bleiben wir
wollen wir hoffen dass er jetzt nicht
auch noch infiziert wird dass die beiden
noch symptome haben denn dann hätten wir
eine situation in der speaker nancy
pelosi auf einmal die aufgaben der
präsidentschaft übernehmen würde das
wirklich den ganzen wahlkampf die ganze
situation in den usa auf den kopf
stellen
der präsident traf auch dafür bekannt
dass er das virus in seiner
kommunikation nicht unbedingt wahnsinnig
ernst genommen hat glauben sie dass das
jetzt noch mal sich ganz deutlich
verändern könnte und wie kann der
präsident das denn jetzt auffangen
er muss hoffen dass er mit leichten
symptomen durchkommt und eben bei der
kommunikation platt und sagt seht ihr
ich habe es geschafft
sozusagen ein teil der risikogruppe weil
er nämlich deutlich älter ist
übergewichtig ist er und er muss hoffen
dass er so durchdacht er kann die
kommunikation nicht mehr ändern wenn er
sich jetzt hinstellt und sagt das hätte
ich ja mal denken können dass das
wirklich gefährlich ist also jetzt
müssen wir echt acht geben dann wäre er
sozusagen mit allem gecrasht was er
bisher gesagt hat nein das wird er nicht
machen können er muss auf den leichten
verlaufen
und da muss hoffen dass er dann
möglicherweise jetzt nochmal nochmal in
der endphase des wahlkampfs wieder
einsteigen kann
professor jäger vielen herzlichen dank
für dieses gespräch
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren